Post-credits scenes are all the rage these
days.
But before those became popular, some movies
included jokes or hidden references within
the actual credits themselves.
Here are some of our favorites from new and
old movies alike.
Frozen boogers
Being a Disney hero is hungry work.
Luckily, Kristoff in Frozen found the perfect
snack to fortify him: his own boogers.
“What if you hate the way he picks his nose?”
“Picks his nose?”
“And eats it.”
“Excuse me sir, he is a prince.”
“All men do it.”
“Ewww”
Even Disney thought that was a bit gross,
though, adding this disclaimer to the credits:
"the views and opinions expressed by Kristoff
in this film that all men eat their own boogers
are solely his and do not necessarily reflect
the views or opinions of The Walt Disney Company
or the filmmakers."
Do no harm
When a movie involves any kinds of animals
or creatures, it's always important for the
filmmakers to ensure the critters' safety.
Even if those animals are CGI.
Pay close attention to the credits in Guardians
of the Galaxy and you'll see confirmation
that no raccoons or tree creatures were in
any way harmed during the production of the
film.
In Harry Potter and the Goblet of Fire, we
learn that "no dragons were harmed in the
making of this movie."
And Mr. Popper's Penguins assures us that
that no penguins were harmed, but, "Jim Carrey,
on the other hand, was bitten mercilessly.
But he had it coming."
No argument here.
Meanwhile, The Naked Gun flicks apparently
revelled in animal cruelty, claiming in the
credits that some entire species went extinct
during principal photography.
“Nice beaver.”
“Thank you, I just had it stuffed.”
"Let me help you with that."
Coffee shop
When the Supreme Court ruled that corporations
are people, they based their decision on Pulp
Fiction.
Okay, that’s not true.
But it could've been.
Why?
During the robbery scene, the restaurant manager’s
dialogue was so obscured by screaming and
swearing that all he could get out was this:
“I am not a hero, I am just a coffee shop…”
So in the credits, Quentin Tarantino decided
to simply name him “Coffee Shop.”
Cozy in the closet
The end credits of Harry Potter and the Prisoner
of Azkaban gives viewers a long look at the
infamous Marauder's Map, which shows the layout
of Hogwarts and all the folks sneaking around
its hallways and rooms.
For a moment during the credits, however,
we see two pairs of feet in the corner of
the screen that don't really sneak so much
as they seem like they might be…knocking
boots?
Who do you think it might be?
Our money is on Professor McGonagall and Professor
Flitwick.
Yikes.
Hello Hanso
Director J.J. Abrams doesn't shy away from
throwing fun Easter eggs into his projects.
Usually it’s just Greg Grunberg.
But during the credits of 2006's Mission:
Impossible III, the filmmakers give a "special
thanks" to the Hanso Foundation.
Of course, true fans will recognize the Hanso
Foundation as the mysterious group that had
a hand in all the crazy island shenanigans
on Abrams' television project, Lost.
Maybe Jack and the rest of the gang got stranded
all because of that damn rabbit's foot…
“Where is the rabbit's foot?”
You have 15 seconds to comply
Most movies contain a warning that the film
is protected under copyright laws in the United
States, followed by some legal mumbo-jumbo.
It's the same disclaimer every time—except
in the case of Robocop.
“I’d buy that for a dollar.”
At the end of the Paul Verhoeven film, the
disclaimer reads, "unauthorized duplication,
distribution or exhibition may result in civil
liability and criminal prosecution by enforcement
droids."
In other words, pirate Robocop and you may
get a visit from ED-209.
Thanks for watching!
Subscribe to our YouTube channel to watch
more videos like the one you just saw.
And leave a comment to let us know which movies
you think should've made the list...